ADRIANA BORDEA: To me,
cuddling is really intimate.
When I really hug someone,
I feel very vulnerable.
So I'm intrigued to
see what it's going
to be like to hug strangers.
My name is Adriana and I'm
going to my first snuggle event.
I kind of don't know what
I'm supposed to be wearing.
I have no idea who
these people are.
I don't know their
ages, their backgrounds.
We're just going to snuggle.
I don't know if
there's, like, rules.
Sometimes I, like,
close people off.
Like, I definitely
put a wall up.
So I think for me, it's
like pushing myself out
of my comfort zone.
I'm about to go in.
I have no idea what's
going to happen.
SHANYA LUTHER: OK.
I'm going to invite everybody
to get cozy for a minute.
My belief about
snuggling is that we
could heal a lot of our
interpersonal wounds
it if we were more connected.
In a culture that
says that you have
to be in a romantic relationship
in order to get touched,
that leaves a lot of people out.
This is a snuggle level event.
What that means is
that we keep our energy
playful and affectionate.
ADRIANA BORDEA: My brain is
a little mushy right now.
I'm shy.
I'm a lot more shy than I
thought I was going to be.
I'm feeling quiet,
a little insecure,
because everyone's very touchy.
So that's out of
my comfort zone.
KARA: My name's Kara.
Just recently have a
relationship, and so
was looking for a place
for some safe touch.
SPEAKER 4: I love giving hugs.
I wish I can give
hugs to everyone,
every day of the week.
SPEAKER 5: I think
snuggling is very important.
This is all about consent.
Just because in this moment I
feel like I want to be spooned,
maybe, you know,
half hour from now,
I'm going to be, like, yeah, no.
KARA: How do I touch
someone without feeling
creepy or weird?
SPEAKER 5: we need touch
to thrive in our lives.
It's very calming.
It's relaxing.
It's comforting-- healing,
you know, with some people.
SPEAKER 6: There's something
about that moment when
you feel a hand or a foot
or an arm and you don't know
whose it is that is
really beautiful.
It's like a connection
to the universal.
ADRIANA BORDEA: I
feel very relaxed now,
which I wasn't a second ago.
I was really anxious.
I think I'm just not used to it.
I'm not used to
touching like that.
And at one point, like everyone
was, like, touching me.
And it was awesome.
I think I lost count of how
many people I snuggled with.
Think it's like we all
yearn for that touch.
It's something that maybe
is not socially acceptable,
but we're just, like, having
a good time snuggling.
ANNOUNCER: Click
here to check out
another video about why
these women are living as men
in Albania.
And as always, click
here to subscribe.